الحمد لله حق
حمده والصلاه والسلام على من لا نبي من
بعده واعلموا عباد الله ان الله تعالى
امرنا بامر بدا فيه بنفسه وثنى
بملائكه قدسه وثلث بالمؤمنين من عالمي جنه
وانسه وقال تعالى قولا كريما تعظيما لقدر
نبينا وتفهما لنا
وتعليما ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا
تسليما اللهم صل وسلم وبارك واكرم وانعم
وتحنن وتعطف على سيدنا محمد طب القلوب
ودوائها وعافيه الابدان
وشفائها ونور الابصار
وضيائها وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا
الله قد افلح من
زكاها وقد خاب من دساها
[Silence]
الامام الغزالي رحمه الله
‏he
and
it bri light from his good for a
hour he
feels
happiness and hope when he says
it then he another ch
‏dark in
disobedience he is
overcome overcome with sadness and
fear he
opens and it
‏by the per
things
life
make reg
رحمه
الله acc to a
beli ex for the after
life suppose that
aob
foren do you think he will
‏re
as الله سبحانه
وتعالى يوم
يجمعكم ليوم
الجمع ذلك يوم
التغابن gather
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى ووضع
الكتاب سور الكهف
الكه
الله سوره
الكهف الله سبحانه
وتالى
الك الله س سبحانه وتعالى ان سوره
الكهف
49 ووضع الكتاب فترى المجرمين مشفقين مما
فيه
ويقولون يا ويلتنا ما لهذا
الكتاب لا يغادر
صغيره ولا كبيره الا
احصاها ووجدوا ما عملوا
ولا يظلم ربك احدا
[Silence]
‏ised they shall face
everything they did and your lord does
not wrong
anyone
muslims it is
important to our souls to the times we
been given ‏for
puic and
refinement the same is true for the
seven part of the
body the
eyes the airs the t
yes the
t the
st
the the private
‏and
sisters there
are and
each the
body for example
[Silence]
‏someone
pleas جزا الله
خي بك الله
فيكم الله سبحانه تعالى
هاز قل للمؤمنات
يغضضن من
ابصاره that
they
their and
also الله سبحانه وتالى
سوره
النور وقل
للمؤمنين يغضوا من
ابصارهم ويحفظ فروجهم
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى refs on the
beauty of allah's
creation he uses his
eyes
قران the of our m عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
قران ولا تقف ما ليس لك به
علم ان
البصر
والفؤاد كل اولئك كان عنه
مسؤولا
وجزم
not not
[Silence]
‏all that
‏ination
eat per
and and sister
الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتالى
so sl
م صلى الله عليه
وسلم معا بن جبل رضي الله تعالى
عنه حال
حرام محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم the people the on their faces for
anything for
their col
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
not is spoken except that a a
angel
rec brothers and
sisters
tance of الله سبحانه وتالى
الله سبحانه
وتعالى
فاذكروني
اذكركم الله سبحانه وتعالى
الا بذكر الله تطمئن
القلوب spe
[Silence]
سهال from all
forms and
from
my
all اللص الا
واعلي كلمتي الحق والدين اللهم اغفر لنا
وارحمنا وتب علينا وسامحنا واختم
بالصالحات اعمالنا اللهم ات انفسنا تقواها
وزكها انت خير من زكاها انت وليها
ومولاها اللهم انا نعوذ بك من علم لا ينفع
ومن قلب لا يخشع ومن عين لا تدمع ومن نفس
لا تشبع ومن دعوه لا يستجاب لك
اللهم اغفر لنا وارحمنا وتب علينا وسامحنا
ولا تحاسبنا على ما فعل السفهاء منا اللهم
فرج هم المهمومين ونفس كرب المكروبين
واعطي سؤل السائلين بكرم ورحمه منك يا
ارحم الراحمين اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين
في كل مكان اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين في
كل مكان اللهم احف دماء المسلمين في كل
مكان
ووهم خيارهم ولا تولهم اشرار ولا تحاسبهم
على ما فعل السفهاء منهم برحمه ومدد ونصر
من عندك يا اكرم الاكرمين ان الله يامر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى
عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون وذكر الله اكبر واقم الصلاه يرحمك
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمد